[Music]
et can confirm Angelina Jolie has filed
for divorce from Brad Pitt citing
irreconcilable differences and now the
actor is speaking out he says in a
statement to People magazine quote I am
very saddened by this but what matters
most now is the well-being of our kids
Jolie is asking for physical custody of
their six children and is asking for
Pitt to have visitation not joint
physical custody Jolie and Pitt married
in August 2014 and have been together
since 2004 after getting close on the
set of mr. and mrs. Smith et last spoke
to the couple at the premiere of their
movie by the sea in November where they
portrayed a troubled pair how was it
that you you get married happiest time
of your life and then all of a sudden
you go up and do this darkly a couple
and on the brink of disaster
right how crazy was that yeah it was
good it was really good it's good time
and uh you know we came out stronger on
the other end
just making some together and something
she wrote it's a real pleasure it's
heavy and it's a lot of fighting it's
pretty ugly and but we had the thought
that if if we can do it if we can be
close in that way and that open as
artists then then you push through and
you really get closer and you learn
something if it doesn't work it's the
worst honeymoon ever but if it works
you've learned something and I think
came out of it stronger
you